(audience cheering)
(uptempo music)
- [Kelly] How are you?
- Nice to see you, I'm great.
- [Kelly] I know, now we're in New York.
- We're in New York.
- The last time
we were in LA when you came, yeah, yeah.
- [Theresa] Now you're on my turf.
- I know, I like it.
I love it here.
- Isn't it amazing?
There's nothing like New York.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you've been
very busy here.
- [Theresa] Yes.
- Yes, you have a new
podcast right now, right?
Do you love it?
- I do, I love.
It's called "Hey Spirit!"
And I love being able to connect people,
you know, all over the world
and, you know, over a Zoom.
It's amazing on how
Spirit really validates
that they're still with us,
it's absolutely incredible.
- Yeah, and it's also
like even scheduling too
in your life, like it's kind of cool,
you can schedule a
podcast more around you.
Which is nice.
- Right?
- Well, Theresa says she connects to those
who have passed on through
something she calls Spirit.
So you say Spirit guides you,
but do you ever feel
that, like physically?
- Yeah, so what happens is
a lot of times when souls,
when they first start
to communicate with me,
they make me feel like the bond
that they shared with the person.
But a lot of times
they'll just bring me
through the departure,
they'll make me feel what they felt
as the soul left the physical body.
- That seems rude.
- Yeah, well, not rude.
(both laughing)
- Oh my God, it seems hard.
- It was rude-
it is very hard.
I would say I make what
I do look very easy,
it's the hardest thing that I have to do,
is to stand in front of someone
and take them on this
emotional rollercoaster
of feeling pain, sorrow, loss, and grief.
And then try to give them peace,
and a little bit of levity and laughter
to know that their loved
ones are still with us.
And that's one of the
reasons why I do what I do,
it's not people to believe
in what I do, I don't care.
I want people to believe in themselves,
to believe in an afterlife,
to know that their loved one's souls
are still with them
just in a different way,
and just to embrace those
things that remind you of them.
- That's beautiful.
So whenever you, say you feel it,
like, do you actually feel it physically,
like feel affected?
- Yeah, like I could feel like,
I already knew when I
was standing back there
that there was a real
tragedy of a departure
because I kept like tasting blood,
and I kept feeling like
a blow to my chest, so.
- Like in the room, like in here-
- When I was standing back
there getting ready to...
Yeah, back there.
- Oh, that, wow, that's heavy.
'Cause then you don't wanna
walk out there and go, "Hey."
- Well, you know, that's the thing,
you know, people came here today,
they didn't come to
maybe expect to see me,
they came to see you, right?
They didn't know I was coming.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- And that's what I always say,
Spirit gives us exactly what we need
to kind of restore our faith,
and to know that they are okay,
and more importantly, that
their soul is at peace.
- It provides probably so
much closure for people,
in just such a peaceful way.
- It does.
You can't imagine how many people pass,
and what people are left
with for whatever reason.
- [Kelly] The (indistinct).
- And some people come, they
don't wanna live anymore,
they don't know how.
There are times where people
haven't spoken to other family members
because someone died.
And someone will come to a reading,
and it will restore their faith,
it'll give them a purpose to live,
they'll reunite families
that haven't spoken.
- [Kelly] Powerful, yeah.
- So it's so much more
than just communicating
with people that have died.
- Absolutely, oh, so your new show,
it say combines readings and
your personal life, right?
- Correct.
- So this is like full on,
do you mind being on
camera a lot like that,
like all the time?
- It's so crazy, like I don't even realize
that they're there-
- [Kelly] I don't either,
I think that's not normal.
- [Theresa] It's normal.
But I don't either.
- [Theresa] To me its normal.
- 'Cause they'll be like,
"Do you mind the cameras here?"
I'm like, "What cameras?"
We'll be somewhere, and
I didn't even see it.
- Well, I talked to dead people,
so they always around, and
nobody else could see it.
So to me at cameras-
(everyone laughing)
- You're like, "They're always here."
- Yes, but it's the most
natural thing for me.
And the thing that I love
about "Raising Spirits,"
it's 'cause I am on the road so much.
And I'm away a lot, and
so they're on, you know,
on the bus with me, they're
seeing what it's like
in a day of a life of me, and then-
- I think people will probably see
how draining it must be and feel,
and that's an emotional roller coaster
all the time, every time
you're talking with someone.
- It sure is, it sure is.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I wouldn't trade what I do
for anything in the physical world.
I consider it an honor and a privilege
to be able to share my gift,
and to give someone
some peace and comfort.
- [Kelly] Beautiful.
- And the fact that people
trust me with the souls of
their departed loved ones,
means the absolute world to me.
So it's an honor to do what I do.
(audience applauding)
- So you told us before,
but remind us what it's like for you
when you start connecting.
- So what happens is I just
feel immediately drawn.
So I was drawn to this area,
but I was more drawn
to this area over here,
down here, and up in here.
And I just keep feeling,
there's just one soul
that keeps bringing me through
a very traumatic departure.
So I keep getting like
a blow to the chest,
and I keep tasting blood,
so that's my symbol for where
someone passed tragically.
And I always say, you
know, like I said earlier,
like nobody came here today thinking that
they might hear from their
loved one that has died.
I always deliver messages-
- [Kelly] So that's heavy.
- It is because sometimes
someone might be afraid,
or not know what to expect
when their loved one does come
through, what they might say.
But I can guarantee you
it will always be things
of faith and healing,
so I don't want anyone to be afraid.
Do you understand the
tragedy up over here, ma'am?
- I mean, (indistinct) passed a week ago.
- A week ago, okay.
And very tragic, is that correct?
Yeah.
- [Theresa] Okay.
- What!
- Yeah, actually.
- So now do you feel like a chill,
or like some type of
warmth move through you?
- A warmth, yeah.
- [Theresa] Okay, I asked
the soul to move through you
to validate that the soul is present.
- Wow.
- [Theresa] Because the
reason why this is happening
because you and the family are afraid
that the soul is not
safe in a peace with God,
is that correct?
- I mean, I think so, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Theresa] Is that correct?
- Yeah.
- So just know that this is the soul's way
of validating that they are okay,
and more importantly,
that we could not have
prevented this departure.
- [Audience Member] Wow.
- Do you understand that?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because I felt like
I needed to take responsibility
for my departure.
- Wow!
- Do you understands
the car accident, okay?
Were you just talking to them?
- Yes!
- They're telling me that, I go,
you're messing up this
reading over here, I'm trying
to do this reading here-
- I'm so sorry.
- So what I love about that-
- I'm so sorry, what?
- Validating for you that they heard you,
do you understand that?
- Yes.
What plans changed that day?
'Cause what happened is
they put me in the car,
and they switched my seat.
So that's my symbol for
that, plans change that day,
they switched cars, or
they switched drivers.
- What?
- Well, we were supposed
to go out together.
I stayed home, I acted like I was asleep.
And she wet with my best friend,
it was both of them in the car.
And usually when we went out together,
I always took a ride with the best friend.
But since I wasn't there, my sister did
'cause she didn't like
going in the car with her.
And they died, they both died-
- [Theresa] And you have
been carrying this burden
for years, for decades.
- Oh my god,
- Validating for you
that they do not want
you to carry this burden
of feeling that if you were there,
or somehow you could
have been responsible,
do you understand that?
Or if you went this
never would've happened.
- Yeah, tell her I missed
her and I love so much.
- You just did, ma'am.
- Oh!
- She also just told me
that you connect with
the song on the radio
that reminds you of her-
- Always!
- It's not a current top 40 hit, right?
- Always.
- [Theresa] You're not
playing it on purpose.
- No.
- Know that that is her soul,
her energy that is with
you at the exact moment.
So know that she wants
to thank you for that,
and know that everything
that you see is truly her,
and that she hasn't left you.
- Oh, thank you so much.
- Don't thank me, thank her.
- Thank (indistinct),
I love you you sissy.
- She's the one that did it.
- I love my sissy, she's the best.
- Oh my God.
- Do we understand
the hitting of the head?
- That was her, that's her.
- Okay, and do you
think that she suffered?
- I think she did, it was
a tragic car accident.
- 'Cause she hit me in
the back of the head.
- Yes.
- And then what she did
is she then had this blow to the chest,
and she made me feel like,
I immediately left the physical body.
- Okay, so I was told that before.
Oh my god, yes.
- She says, "I need you to believe
"that I did not suffer to my death,
"or if anyone got to me sooner,
that I would still be here."
- Thank God.
- Know that my soul immediately left.
- Oh, thank you God.
- I'm very sorry for the loss
of your sister.
- Thank you so much,
thank you so much.
- I wish you all the best.
- I appreciate you.
- Thank you.
- God, you do this
all the time, this is so intense.
(audience applauding)
- I could keep going.
- This is so intense.
- [Theresa] Yeah.
- That was overwhelming
to just be in the room
while all of that just went down,
and you do that regularly, like?
- And I could still go.
I mean, 'cause it's
almost like I felt like
when I first came out, people
like thinking, "Oh, my God."
And then it's almost like,
"Oh, well I wonder if
my loved one is here."
I think that was me, I should speak up,
I should say something.
So I just say to you all,
just embrace and know that the
things that go on around you
that remind you of your
loved one that has died,
to know that that is them,
know that there is an afterlife.
And that they will greet us
when we do leave this physical world.
I can feel like there are so many people
that have a million questions,
a million questions right now.
And I understand, and I read what respect.
What I do is not for everyone,
and I will never force messages on anyone.
- I can see how that might scare someone
to where they'd be quiet about it,
and then talk about it later.
- [Theresa] A 1000%, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
And that's okay.
- It freaked me the hell out.
(everyone laughing)
Well give it up Theresa Caputo everybody.
(audience applauding)
Theresa Caputo, "Raising
the Spirits" premiers
on Lifetime tomorrow night,
and catch her on tour.
Theresa Caputo, Live The
Experience, go online for tickets.